[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous moi je suis toujours
étonné de venir parler devant un public
de voyages d' aventure parce que j'ai un
petit peu comme l'impression qu'il ya
toujours un paradoxe entre les personnes
tranquillement ainsi sur leur canapé et
puis moi qui leur parle un petit peu d'
aventure ça mais ça m'intrigue toujours
surtout qu'il ya souvent des questions
qui viennent derrière derrière ça qu'ils
disent ouais bah alors ça allait niveau
de la sécurité
c'était pas trop compliqué où vous avez
eu à manger tous les jours et je suis
toujours surpris par ces questions moi
j'aurais plutôt envie de leur parler des
couchers de soleil que j'ai vu et tout
ça est peu à peu à force d'entendre ces
questionnements là bas je me suis posé
la question et je me suis rendu compte à
quel point en fait on était tous très
très ancré dans ses dents cette pyramide
de maslow que vous connaissez sûrement
tous donc qui commence avec les besoins
physiologiques donc par exemple manger
boire dormir
ensuite on allait les besoins de
sécurité les besoin d'appartenance
d'estimé de soi et de réalisations et en
fait on part du principe qu'il faut
remplir les un peu les les cases du bas
avant de pouvoir allait s'élever un
petit peu vers l'est vers la réalisation
et vers les choses un petit peu plus
élevé et c'est étonnant parce que
finalement cette pyramide peu à peu j'ai
l'impression que dans notre société elle
devient elle devient ça en fait cette
espèce de grosse birp voilà on a les
besoins physiologiques
on a les besoins de sécurité
l'appartenance encore ça ils sont bien
bien exacerbée peut le voir un petit peu
partout et puis le reste c'est oublier
la réalisation de soi alors là parce
qu'on est tellement là dedans et puis
c'est comme une soif sans fin quoi on
est on les remplit cela mais on en veut
toujours plus on est toujours plus de
sécurité toujours plus avoir à manger à
boire et finalement on oublie totalement
la partie la partie supérieure est alors
moi j'avais en étant ici élèves à lui
stp j'avais un petit peu peur de ça en
étant dans mes études et j'ai commencé
un petit peu à partir à l'aventuré à
partir en stop
à voyager alors j'avais une grande soif
de défis un petit peu découverte aussi
d'aller découvrir le monde et d'aller
faire des rencontres un petit peu
partout et donc j'ai commencé à voyager
voyager alors en france en europe en
amérique latine et alors quand on est en
stop c'est assez drôle parce que tous
ses besoins dont je vous ai parlé
baladins coup ils disparaissent un petit
peu on l'aimé vraiment à leur portion
congrue
par exemple le besoin de physiologiques
de manger de boire
bon ben moi il m'arrive quand je fais du
stock ne pas manger pendant une journée
parce que je suis tellement pris dans
les dents les dans les conversations
dans le fait d'avancer de rencontrer des
gens et puis j'arrive pas forcément à
des endroits où j'ai à manger je mange
pas forcément je dors un petit peu
n'importe où sur une station service où
je peu à peu près dans les camions aussi
temps en temps et puis pareil pour
l'appartenance bajeux je quitte mon mes
amis je quitte un petit peu tout le
monde et puis je passe d'une personne à
l'autre comme ça et niveau estime de soi
quand on attend quelques heures ou
quelques dizaines d'heures au bord d'une
route
un mot commence vraiment à douter on se
dit qu'on a un petit peu idiot d'avoir
de cette nuit là alors qu'on aurait pu
prendre un bus un train n'importe quel
autre transport et donc là on est
vraiment à 0 et puis et puis finalement
ça avance par contre niveau de la
réalisation là on avant on est plutôt
pas mal
et alors j'ai pas mal voyagé comme je
vous disais en europe et alors j'ai
envie de vous parler d'un trajet en
particulier c'est celui qu'on voit en
bleu alors j'ai commencé ici à paris gt
gt justement à le stp j'avais quatre
jours et demi de vacances et je me suis
battu je vais aller rejoindre des amis
qui sont à vienne on va aller faire un
peu la fête et puis après je vais
revenir
donc c'était un gros défi à 1200 km je
commence à partir je suis pris par des
crs au départ puis puis je commence à
avancer un petit peu je me retrouve sur
une station service et là je me retrouve
bloqué toute la nuit plus toute la
matinée j'étais encore qu'à metz pas
trop avancé
et j'ai commencé à me poser des
questions et puis là il ya quelqu'un qui
me prend alors tenez vous bien c'est un
producteur de rap allemand il revenait
tanzanie il veut en nouvelle-zélande
mais qui était totalement fascinant
vraiment et il faisait passer pile la
partie compliquée de mon voyage qui
était cette bifurcation là un petit peu
compliqué il m'emmenait assez loin et ce
qui fait qu'à midi j'étais encore en
france et le soir même j'arrivais à
vienne assez génial pour eux de
rejoindre mes amis et puis après le
retour c'est pareil c'est fait par une
autre un autre trajet un petit peu le
hasard du stop et puis une des toutes
dernières voitures qui m'a pris on m'a
proposé aussi de m'embaucher pendant ce
voyage d'ailleurs il des dernières vont
être sûr qu'il m'a pris le gamin on
discute un peu et puis il m'explique que
va lui il voyageait pas mal par son
métier maintenant et que son fils avait
aussi cette ut cette envie de partir
voyager à la fin de ses études qui était
aussi en qu'il avait fait une école
d'ingénieurs et que finalement on lui
avait proposé le travail après le
travail de fin d'études on lui avait
proposé un emploi puis l'avait dit oui
et puis il était jamais parti il m'a dit
je sens que tu veux partir et ben si tu
veux partir voyager fait le à la fin de
tes études construit bien projet est
comme ça il y aura plus il y aura plus
rien qui pourra empêcher de partir et
c'est ce que j'ai fait avec mon cousin
on s'est appelé on a commencé à monter
tout un tout un grand voyage qui était
un tour du monde à vélo
alors vous voyez un petit peu partie
vers l'europe de l'est la turquie et
l'iran l'asie centrale l'inde l'asie du
sud-est et l'amérique du sud qu'on a
tracé un peu cet itinéraire sur une
carte cantons restant un petit peu large
on a prévu un peu ce qu'on aurait besoin
d'avoir dans nos vélos pendant pendant
un an donc de quoi dormir de quoi de
quoi filmer de quoi se vêtir de quoi
manger au cas où
et puis de quoi réparer nous et les
vélos et puis pas beaucoup plus en fait
finalement pendant un an on a vécu avec
ça et on a baptisé les vélos avec des
anciens justement de stp puis on est
parti
et alors c'est très drôle parce que
pendant un voyage comme ça on est passés
par des conditions assez extrêmes on
dormait très souvent soit sous la tente
sont chez l'habitant jamais d'hôtel est
en fête
tous nos besoins en fait on était on
était dans une
dans un dépassement de tous nos besoins
assez classique en fait cela ils étaient
vraiment là à ce niveau là vraiment au
niveau très très très faible mais par
contre ce qui est drôle c'est que
finalement en les dépassant
il nous arrivait assez naturellement
c'est à dire que nous on était purement
dans notre dans notre dans notre
réalisation de nous mêmes on était on
était en plein dedans bien alignées et
en fait finalement l'estiment elle
venait au fur et à mesure en fait qu'on
était en train d'avancer qu'on voyait
sur notre compteur les les milliers de
kilomètres qui commençait à sa fiche et
on a fait 18 dans tout et puis les
besoins de l'appartenance
finalement il se faisait avec tout le
monde il y avait il y avait toujours ce
on était tous partout chez nous en fait
finalement on était tout le temps très
bien accueilli on sentait bien avec les
personnes la sécurité
ben c'est pareil on pourrait se dire
avec un vélo c'est dangereux on est et
en fait on était très exposée mais
finalement on n'était pas en danger
parce que les gens nous disaient
toujours les endroits où on balaie les
endroits où faire attention et puis on
santé à ce niveau là on sentait quand il
fallait pas aller à un endroit on savait
aussi gérer les situations compliquées
et les besoins physiologiques va
finalement s'en préoccuper assez peu
bien sûr on a et tous les soirs on
arrivait à manger on arrivait à on avait
de quoi boire on trouvait toujours de
quoi se réapprovisionner
puis on trouver très facilement où
dormir c'est à dire que trois quarts des
nuits on les a dormi on a dormi chez
d'habitants donc l'attend elle servait
quasiment plus la garantie qu'on avait à
août et les gens qu'on avait qu'on
rencontrait aussi était été aussi m'a un
petit peu dans ce dépassement on a
rencontré beaucoup de gens qui
dépassaient leurs besoins
pure de la pyramide de maslow par
exemple on a été accueillis en asie
centrale
si vous pouvez aussi vous voyez un petit
peu les maisons comment elle était faite
les pièces servait à tous les usages
donc on mangeait au même endroit ont
déployé une nappe
et puis ensuite ont déployé des nattes
pour dormir voilà donc il vivait avec
assez peu en iran les gens qui avaient
aussi très peu étaient nous
nous offrait de la nourriture en bord de
route il avait peu mais mais il voulait
quand même nous offrir parce qu'on était
des voyageurs on arrivait il voulait il
voulait partager ça avec nous et en inde
alors là on est tombés sur des grosses
fête hindouiste et on a rencontré des
sadou donc c'est des gens vraiment qu'il
renonce à tout bien matériel pour se
consacrer à leur quête spirituelle et
donc ils vivent avec absolument rien
certains vivent même nue et nous inde
est un des gros sujets aussi qu'on
creuse et pendant tout ce voyage c'était
l'écologie on était parti sur ce thème
les consciences écologiques dans les
pays dits émergents et en fait on a on
s'est rendu compte à quel point on était
bien au delà de nos limites nous ont
pensé qu'on en tant qu'ingénieur je
pensais qu'avec les solutions techniques
on arriverait à solutionner le problème
écologique disais on va on va bien
trouver des choses on va aller voir ce
qui existe dans le monde puis peu à peu
on s'est rendu compte qu'avec les les
montagnes de plastique par exemple qui
arrive en inde alors que pourtant ils
polluent peu par rapport à un français
les la déforestation massive dans
certaines zones du monde l'agriculture
qui est un ravage pour les pour les
paysans eux-mêmes la pollution de l'air
la pollution de l'eau le dérèglement
climatique aussi qui arrivait qu'on a vu
très frontalement dans l'est dans les
andes
c'est dit c'est pas possible et en plus
les cultures qui pourrait un petit peu
lutter contre ça soit en train de se
déliter et on se demandait vraiment
comment on allait sortir de cette
ornière
heureusement il y avait des gens qui
fonctionnait un petit peu différemment
qu'ont rencontrées sur le chemin qui
avait une autre approche des choses on
sentait qu'ils étaient passés au delà de
haut niveau des besoins et ça nous a
poussés après nous à vouloir partager
toutes ses touches constat assez dur et
puis aussi les porteurs de solutions qui
émergeait partout dans le monde qui
travaillaient plus sur un changement
d'être plutôt que sur la voir et ben moi
j'ai vraiment eu à coeur de au retour de
ne pas retomber dans le moment très
difficile d'un voyage c'est quand on
vient et j'avais pas envie de retomber
dans une dans une façon de faire à ces
consuméristes ce que j'avais appris que
je pouvais fonctionner totalement
différemment
j'avais j'avais
j'avais vraiment envie aussi de partager
ce que j'avais appris d'aller d'aller de
continuer dans ce jeu bonne réalisation
de moi donc j'ai décidé de pas sur mon
parcours d'ingénieur est plutôt passé du
temps à m'occuper du de la réalisation
du documentaire du montage et ensuite le
film est sorti sur cette aventure qui
s'appelle the green wood et on a on l'a
partagée plus de 300 fois un peu partout
en france
et peu à peu ce travail a servi à aider
d'autres voyageurs à eux mêmes allés au
bout de leur projet de voyage qui a
pouvoir le partager
donc aujourd'hui on en accompagnant une
quarantaine avec des projets tous aussi
fous les uns que les autres et je vais
juste vous parlez d'un kill qui est bien
dans notre thématique ces deux
ingénieurs aussi qu'ils sont partis au
népal à vélo leur projet s'appelle
direction népal et eux c'est assez drôle
parce que leur voyage leur a permis
d'apprendre à quel point d'apprendre un
petit peu en humanité ça veut dire que
accueilli par les gens pendant tout leur
voyage et puis ensuite arriver on n'est
pas là pour aider à reconstruire et se
rendant compte qu'ils étaient finalement
même si cet ingénieur bâtiment
il n'avait pas pas pas grand chose à
apprendre aux gens sur place
eh ben ils ont une vision a pris une
grande humilité ça sent aujourd'hui
quand on les voit et ils n'ont pas
choisi la même voie que moi ils ont
décidé de retourner sur le chantier
après après leur périple est d'emmener
un petit peu tout ce qu'ils avaient
appris sur le chantier et de d'être
d'être profondément ces personnes
humaines ces personnes attentionné
qu'ils avaient pu voir pendant leur
périple est souvent les qualifie comme
les plus heureux du chantier il me
raconte
parce que justement ils ont cette façon
d'être comme ça et c'est drôle on a
choisi de voix différentes mais
finalement sur le retour en fait on a
tous les deux à la fois inversée note
notre retourner notre pyramide de maslow
et finalement quand on vient on a aussi
des besoins de vie donc cette pyramide
de maslow allait elle est aussi là on
peut pas la nier
et en fait ça fait ça fait alors on les
en les conjuguant ces deux pyramides
dans un sens et dans l'autre je suis
tombé sur le
ce qui est le sceau de salomon en fait
alors depuis elle est devenue la croix
de david et c'est devenu un truc
politique mais c'est pas mon pas du tout
mon sujet ça au départ c'est le sceau de
salomon et salomon c'était un roi qui
était connu pour être extrêmement sage
qui était connu pour être à l'équilibré
des choses il était aussi connu comme un
sûrement le roi le plus riche de tous
les temps alors moi je me pose toujours
la question de la richesse parce que
nous on la voit de notre point de vue du
point de vue du bas de la pyramide de
maslow vraiment très matérielles mais
finalement sa richesse est ce qu elle
était aussi matérielles que ce qu'on se
compensent nous en tout cas en se
mettant en étant en essayant d'être au
quotidien au centre de cette de 7,2 ce
bien hexagram et vint finalement on est
on est vraiment où un petit peu au pil
pil dans la finesse du bon placement
dans la vie et c'est ce que ce que c'est
ce que je m'efforce de faire peu à peu
et j'ai découvert aussi que c'était
quelque chose d'être d'être comme ça au
centre de ce2 ce2 cet équilibre c'est
quelque chose qui a toujours existé en
fait qui a toujours existé dans l'est
dans tous les grands mythes
alors ici on a on a dans toutes les
histoires un petit peu initiatique
on a différentes histoires donc l'otan
princesse mononoké que certains
connaissent peut-être que les romans de
la table ronde les seigneurs des anneaux
ou encore quelque chose de beaucoup plus
vieux l'épopée de gilgamesh est le nôtre
notre histoire est peut-être notre
enfance aussi est peuplé de récits comme
ça qui sont hautement initiatique qui
raconte comment dans la vie on peut
continuer à cheminer à passer des étapes
pour rester dans la droiture de notre
être et toutes ces choses existent mais
en fait on les a beaucoup laissé de côté
et donc moi je sais ce que j'essaie
aujourd'hui de faire en avançant dansez
dansez dansez cheminement pour essayer
de d'avancer dans la voie
je dirais la voie droite certains
l'appellent alcide attal moustaki et
et par exemple alors là j'ai envie de
m'adresser aux futurs ingénieurs qui ce
qui se trouve dans cette salle ça ça
peut vouloir dire aussi à la fin de la
fin de ses études de rester dans cette
attention à ne pas à ne pas aller dans
l'espèce d'affaissement qu'on peut très
vite avoir de la pyramide de maslow
quand on sort des études parce qu'on
nous propose un bon travail des bonnes
conditions et finalement on se laisse
attraper et l'idée c'est aussi de rester
toujours dans ses rêves d'enfant danser
dans ce qu'on voulait apporter au monde
et de garder cette attention toujours à
la réalisation de 2 soit dans ce qu'on
fait donc ça peut être en construisant
des maisons de manière plus plus
vertueuse
ça peut aussi être en pensant à la
réalisation de même des gens qui vont
vivre dans ces maisons parce
qu'aujourd'hui on construit beaucoup
pour essayer de un petit peu de répondre
aux besoins comme ça on se dit les gens
ont des besoins on y répond très très
fondamentalement et ça va mais non j'ai
pu voir dans le monde des maisons en
terre ou là c'était plus vraiment dû
pour le bien vivre des gens donc il ya
vraiment cette attention à voir ça passe
aussi par un autre une autre façon de
manager vous allez parfois vous
retrouvez à la à la tête d'organisations
très vite très jeune et on a un peu ce
besoin de sécurité qui vient et on se
met au dessus des autres et non là aussi
à inverser la pyramide et se mettent au
service se met vraiment vraiment un
service c'est pas simplement tout un
apprentissage et ça peut vouloir dire
aussi de finalement fin finalement cette
chose-là peu ça nous emmène à être
vraiment au service à rester tout le
temps au service de ses idéaux qu'on
avait avant et moi je suis persuadé que
c'est par ce changement d'attitude de
chacun et d'autant plus quand on est aux
responsabilités qu'on va pouvoir m'a
peut-être dépassé ce mur dans lequel on
est en train de foncer tout droit au
niveau du dérèglement climatique au
niveau social au niveau sociétal
finalement et peut-être de voir aussi le
monde différemment de voir le reste du
monde comme pas seulement nos rapports
des besoins on apporte des besoins aux
pays émergents aux personnes qui sont
dans le besoin par exemple aux migrants
qui viennent
mais se dire qu'est ce que ces gens
cherchent aussi en relisant réalisation
de même et c'est peut-être là d'un
changement de paradigme dans notre façon
de voir le monde qu'il faut avoir
et finalement dans tout ça je vous
appelle je vous appelle à ne pas rester
sur la rive mais vraiment à tout le
temps resté au quotidien des aventuriers
tout le temps tout le temps sur la
brèche
merci à vous tous